jordan peterson among being a mouthpiece  for many horrible movements has now  become a mouthpiece for the climate  science denial movement the climate  crisis denial movement a nightmarish  vision  of environmental apocalypse  outlandish claims we covered on the  david pakman show on the youtube channel  which i hope you're subscribed to a few  weeks ago months ago his uh sobbing  over the horrors of telling young people  that the planet is in trouble they've  been told since they were little that  there's nothing to them but corruption  and power the real horror is that the  planet is in trouble jordan peterson  said and then got angry with me on  twitter by the way for reporting on it  that the problem is telling young people  that the climate is in trouble because  it will make them sad  sky is truly dangerous